Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. From an early age, I have been traveling a lot. The differences, the darkness of the received impressions of countries and people, of states and things, have offered me instruction, satisfaction, and joy. No wonder that, from early on, a wanderlust developed in me which finally culminated in the desire to accomplish a voyage around the world. This wish has been fulfilled. What pushed me was the pursuit of the following.
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我从小就经常旅行。不同国家、不同人民、不同国家体制和事物所带来的差异与深刻印象，给予了我教导、满足和快乐。难怪我从小就萌生了漫游的渴望，最终演变成环游世界的愿望。这个愿望已经实现了。推动我前进的是对以下目标的追求。
To achieve insight from personal observation of other parts of the world into foreign institutions and communities, to come into contact with foreign people, to learn from foreign cultures and customs, to enjoy the sights of the wonderful works of art and foreign nature and its inexhaustible allure in the open sea, on firm ground, in princely palaces, in meager huts, in metropolises, in solitary wilderness, in lush lowlands, in clear mountain heights, have I found what I have been looking for rich in experiences, in rare prizes, in collections, have I returned home. So that, Dominic, was the preface to an account of traveling around the world, which was published in 1896 by Franz Ferdinand, the Archduke who, let's face up to it, has a truly terrible day on the 28th of June 1914. He does indeed. But before we come to that, let's have a look at his life, his character, and more broadly than that,
通过亲身观察世界其他地区的外国制度和社区，与外国人民接触，学习外国文化和习俗，欣赏奇妙的艺术作品和异国自然风光，以及在公海、陆地、王宫、简陋小屋、大都市、荒野、茂密低地、清澈山巅所感受到的无穷魅力，我找到了我所寻找的一切。带着丰富的经历、珍贵的收获和收藏，我回到了家。所以，多米尼克，这就是1896年弗朗茨·斐迪南大公出版的环球旅行记的前言。这位大公，我们不得不承认，在1914年6月28日度过了极其糟糕的一天。确实如此。但在我们谈到那一天之前，让我们先看看他的生平、性格，以及更广泛地，
the whole world in which he inhabits, the world of the Austro-Hungarian Empire. And to do that, we've moved from the cafe, which was a very kind of Gavrilo Prince place to kind of hang out, wasn't it? It was. We've come to it, well, it markets itself as a Viennese cafe. So a kind of Habsburg vibe. It's got a very Habsburg vibe
他所居住的整个世界，即奥匈帝国的世界。为了做到这一点，我们离开了咖啡馆，那是一个非常适合加夫里洛·普林西普（Gavrilo Princip）消磨时光的地方，不是吗？确实是。我们来到了这里，嗯，它自称是一家维也纳咖啡馆。所以有一种哈布斯堡的氛围。它确实有一种非常浓厚的哈布斯堡氛围。
in the Hotel Europa in Sarajevo. Hello, everybody. I hope you enjoyed that little bit of audio footage of Franz Ferdinand talking as much as I did, and judging by their horrified expressions, the waiters did. So yes, so that preface actually is quite interesting. There's a website called Franz Ferdinand's World, and it gives you all his accounts. So he wrote this book about his voyage around the world, the Archduke Franz Ferdinand, who's of course known now only for one thing which is being shot in sarajevo two things in my case because he's also known for an
在萨拉热窝的欧洲酒店。大家好。希望你们和我一样喜欢那段弗朗茨·斐迪南讲话的音频片段，从服务员惊恐的表情来看，他们显然也很喜欢。所以，是的，那篇前言其实很有趣。有一个叫“弗朗茨·斐迪南的世界”的网站，上面有他所有的记录。弗朗茨·斐迪南大公写了这本关于他环球旅行的书，他现在当然只因一件事而闻名，那就是在萨拉热窝被枪杀。对我来说是两件事，因为他还因一张
extraordinary photograph that was taken of him in egypt where he dressed up as a mummy he did and he's kind of wrapped up and he's in a in a sarcophagus and his little bless him his little austrian face peering out with his whiskers and everything. Exactly. And I think anyone who is interested in the interface of Egyptology and the Austro-Hungarian empire, I mean, you love that photo. There are many such people. So actually the reason I thought that would be a fun introduction, not just because it would give you such a wonderful opportunity to show off your mastery of different voices, but also it's a Franz Ferdinand we don't normally think of. So we think of Franz Ferdinand the man
非凡的照片而闻名，那是在埃及拍摄的，他打扮成木乃伊的样子。他确实这样做了，他被包裹起来，躺在石棺里，他那张小小的、可怜的奥地利脸庞露在外面，留着胡须等等。没错。我想任何对埃及学和奥匈帝国交集感兴趣的人，都会喜欢那张照片。有很多人都喜欢。所以，我之所以认为这是一个有趣的开场白，不仅因为它给了你一个绝佳的机会来展示你模仿不同声音的功力，还因为它展现了一个我们通常不会想到的弗朗茨·斐迪南。我们通常认为弗朗茨·斐迪南这个男人
shot in Sarajevo as the incarnation of kind of stolid Habsburg conservatism so in that impression I was kind of channeling an Austrian walrus yes that's what I had in mind Austrian walrus exactly but that's not entirely fair is it no so that journey around the world he did it in December 1892 and it took him the best part of a year. He came back the following October. It's actually an amazing journey, Tom. Egypt, Aden, Sri Lanka, India, Nepal, Singapore, Java, Hong Kong, China, Japan, New Guinea, Australia, New Caledonia, Borneo, Canada, the United States. I mean, there's surely a case that at the beginning of the 20th century, the Archduke Franz Ferdinand had been to more interesting places than almost anybody else on earth.
在萨拉热窝被枪杀，是那种刻板的哈布斯堡保守主义的化身。所以在那段模仿中，我是在模仿一只奥地利海象。是的，我当时就是这么想的，奥地利海象，没错。但这并不完全公平，对吧？不。所以那次环球旅行，他在1892年12月进行，历时近一年。他于次年10月返回。汤姆，这实际上是一次了不起的旅程。埃及、亚丁、斯里兰卡、印度、尼泊尔、新加坡、爪哇、香港、中国、日本、新几内亚、澳大利亚、新喀里多尼亚、婆罗洲、加拿大、美国。我的意思是，肯定有理由认为，在20世纪初，弗朗茨·斐迪南大公去过的地方比地球上几乎任何人都更有趣。
And it was brave of him to go to America, bearing in mind what happened... To his uncle, Maximilian. To his uncle, Maximilian, who ended up shot. That's right. He actually goes to America. He goes to the great Chicago World's Fair in 1893. He arrived in a private Pullman car,
而且他去美国是很勇敢的，考虑到发生了什么……他的叔叔马克西米利安。他的叔叔马克西米利安，最终被枪杀了。没错。他确实去了美国。他去了1893年伟大的芝加哥世博会。他乘坐一辆名为“吉祥物”（Mascot）的私人普尔曼车厢抵达，
which was called Mascot. Had a brilliant time. And I think what all this reminds us is that actually, well, he is a much more interesting, complicated, and surprising person, I think, than the Austrian walrus caricature. So the whole point of this series is to explain how and why the First World War began. And actually, rather like Gavrilo Princip princip the archduke is often just written off as a bit of a cipher and a footnote in history really and as we'll see today he is not a footnote in history and actually his story is an excellent way to understand the austro-hungarian empire how it worked what its future was and the kind of some of the geopolitical dynamics in sort of east Central Europe at the beginning of the 1910s.
度过了一段美好的时光。我认为这一切提醒我们，实际上，他是一个比“奥地利海象”的漫画形象更有趣、更复杂、更令人惊讶的人。所以这个系列的全部意义在于解释第一次世界大战是如何以及为什么开始的。实际上，就像加夫里洛·普林西普一样，大公经常被视为历史上的一个符号和注脚。正如我们今天将看到的，他并不是历史的注脚，实际上，他的故事是了解奥匈帝国、它的运作方式、它的未来以及20世纪10年代初中东欧地缘政治动态的一个绝佳切入点。
And I think that British listeners in particular will find certain echoes of dynamics in our own beloved royal family. They will indeed. Because he's the nephew, not the son, of the ruling emperor. That's right. The ruling emperor, I mean, he's been in power forever. And there is a kind of Elizabeth II quality. To Franz Joseph, yes.
我认为英国听众尤其会发现其中与我们心爱的王室动态产生了一些共鸣。确实会。因为他是现任皇帝的侄子，而不是儿子。没错。现任皇帝，我的意思是，他已经掌权很久了。有一种伊丽莎白二世的特质。弗朗茨·约瑟夫确实有。
To Franz Joseph, the emperor of Austria-Hungary. Absolutely there is. Christopher Clarke in his brilliant book, Sleepwalkers, says how people dream of Franz Joseph. He haunts their sleep. And that's what people say of the queen, in a similar way.
奥匈帝国皇帝弗朗茨·约瑟夫。绝对有。克里斯托弗·克拉克在他那本出色的《梦游者》中说，人们如何梦见弗朗茨·约瑟夫。他萦绕在他们的梦中。人们对女王的评价也类似。
Yes. So Franz Josephph the emperor of austria-hungary came to the throne in 1848 and he'd seen two massive defeats in the first couple of decades of his reign one was at solferino where they lost the austro-hungarians lost northern italy and one was at koeniggratz where they lost to prussia and they basically lost control of Germany. In 1863, Franz Ferdinand was born in Graz in southern Austria. He's the son of Franz Joseph's younger brother, Karl Ludwig, and his mother is a princess of the two Sicilies, Princess Maria Annunziata.
是的。所以奥匈帝国皇帝弗朗茨·约瑟夫于1848年登基，他在统治的前几十年里经历了两次惨败，一次是在索尔费里诺，奥匈帝国失去了意大利北部；另一次是在克尼格雷茨，他们输给了普鲁士，基本上失去了对德国的控制。1863年，弗朗茨·斐迪南出生在奥地利南部的格拉茨。他是弗朗茨·约瑟夫的弟弟卡尔·路德维希的儿子，他的母亲是两西西里王国的公主，玛丽亚·安农齐亚塔公主。
She's a Bourbon. And he's growing up in an empire that has had to completely recalibrate itself it's shrunk because it's lost some of its territory so again quite like elizabeth ii yes uh when he's three in 1867 the austrians and the hungarians agreed what was called the compromise and the way this worked was that the empire would effectively become a kind of strange federation. Half of it was the Empire of Austria, and half of it was the Kingdom of Hungary. And there were different nationalities under each of those. So for example, Croatia was run by the Hungarians. Transylvania was run by the Hungarians. But for instance, Galicia, so what is now Poland, a bit of Poland and a bit of Ukraine,
她是波旁家族的人。他在一个不得不彻底重组的帝国中长大，因为它失去了一些领土，所以这又很像伊丽莎白二世。是的，当他三岁时，即1867年，奥地利人和匈牙利人达成了所谓的“妥协”。这种运作方式是，帝国实际上变成了一种奇怪的联邦。一半是奥地利帝国，另一半是匈牙利王国。每个部分下都有不同的民族。例如，克罗地亚由匈牙利人管理。特兰西瓦尼亚由匈牙利人管理。但例如加利西亚，也就是现在的波兰的一部分和乌克兰的一部分，
that was part of the austrian half and it seems a little bit unwieldy but actually franz joseph the emperor keeps it together he is the symbol of stability that glues it together he's very serious he's very hard working he's actually intensely conservative you know the elizabeth the second comparison is a good one because like her he is the embodiment of dutifulness of duty yeah he famously sleeps in this kind of iron bed um he's very frugal he gets up at kind of four o'clock in the morning to do his paperwork he's boring and the boringness is the is the brand so his famous saying that he says every day multiple times a day when he visits some town or he says it was nice we were quite pleased yeah he never says anything but that yeah but there's something also faintly forbidding about him almost kind of
那是奥地利那一半的一部分。这看起来有点笨重，但实际上皇帝弗朗茨·约瑟夫把它维持在一起。他是将这一切粘合在一起的稳定象征。他非常严肃，非常勤奋，实际上非常保守。你知道，伊丽莎白二世的比较很贴切，因为像她一样，他是尽职尽责的化身。是的，他以睡在那种铁床上而闻名，他非常节俭，早上四点钟起床处理文书工作。他很无聊，而这种无聊就是他的品牌。所以他每天多次访问某个城镇时都会说那句名言：“很好，我们很满意。”是的，他从不说别的。但关于他也有一些隐约令人敬畏的东西，几乎像是一种
undead so there's a famous description of him in the Radetzky March, the Joseph Roth novel, coffered up in an icy and everlasting old age, like an armor of an awe-inspiring crystal. Yeah, nice. Sorry, Tom, I'm in the middle of, we've literally ordered some Sasha Torta to get into the kind of... I've got some cake. The Habsburg vibe. Couldn't be more Viennese. And I think for Franz Ferdinand, growing up in that world, it is quite a forbidding and intimidating world to grow up in.
不死生物。所以约瑟夫·罗特的小说《拉德茨基进行曲》中有一段关于他的著名描述：“被禁锢在冰冷而永恒的老年之中，就像一件令人敬畏的水晶盔甲。”是的，不错。抱歉，汤姆，我正在……我们刚刚点了一些萨赫蛋糕来感受那种……我有一些蛋糕。哈布斯堡的氛围。再维也纳不过了。我认为对于在那个世界长大的弗朗茨·斐迪南来说，那是一个相当令人敬畏和胆怯的世界。
So all the accounts of his boyhood, you know, there are different versions, but he seems to have been a very quiet, worried, awkward kind of boy. He's tutored at home. His mother died when he was very young, when he was about seven. He has a younger brother called Otto, who is basically more fun, more clever, more popular.
所以所有关于他童年的记录，你知道，有不同的版本，但他似乎是一个非常安静、忧虑、笨拙的男孩。他在家里接受辅导。他的母亲在他很小的时候，大约七岁时就去世了。他有一个弟弟叫奥托，基本上更有趣、更聪明、更受欢迎。
Total kind of older brother. You and I are both older brothers, aren't we, Tom? So we have a lot of fellow feeling with Franz Ferdinand. Yeah, and the more charismatic brother. Yeah. The other problem he has is he's obviously completely eclipsed by his cousin, the emperor's son. So his cousin is Crown Prince Rudolf. And anybody who knows anything about Habsburg history will know
完全是那种哥哥的样子。你和我都是哥哥，对吧，汤姆？所以我们对弗朗茨·斐迪南有很多同感。是的，还有那个更有魅力的弟弟。是的。他面临的另一个问题是，他显然完全被他的堂兄，即皇帝的儿子所掩盖。所以他的堂兄是皇储鲁道夫。任何了解哈布斯堡历史的人都会知道
Crown Prince Rudolf is a pretty extraordinary character he is very charming he is unreliable he's mercurial he's he's he's idealistic um he's like you tom he loves fossils and minerals and stuff but he's also me he's driven mad by syphilis isn't he yes well as far as we yeah so far i mean driven mad yet no so he's ravaged by gonorrhea and syphilis isn't he yes well as far as we yeah so far i mean driven mad yet no so he's ravaged by gonorrhea and syphilis he becomes a morphine addict and in 1889 a point of difference again a point of difference in 1889 when rudolph was 30 and franz ferdinand was 25 rudolph killed himself in a kind of suicide pact with his teenage mistress maria vetsera at the meierling hunting lodge this incredible story the subject of films and operas and so on and so forth now rudolph was the only
皇储鲁道夫是一个非常非凡的人物。他非常有魅力，不可靠，反复无常，理想主义。他像你一样，汤姆，他喜欢化石和矿物之类的东西。但他也被梅毒逼疯了，不是吗？是的，就我们所知……是的，到目前为止，我的意思是，被逼疯了……不，所以他被淋病和梅毒摧毁了，不是吗？是的，就我们所知……是的，到目前为止，我的意思是，被逼疯了……不，所以他被淋病和梅毒摧毁了。他成了吗啡成瘾者，并在1889年——又一个分歧点——1889年，当鲁道夫30岁，弗朗茨·斐迪南25岁时，鲁道夫在梅耶林狩猎小屋与他十几岁的情妇玛丽亚·维塞拉一起自杀。这个不可思议的故事是电影和歌剧的主题等等。现在，鲁道夫是皇帝唯一的
son of the emperor under other circumstances the the crown the role of the heir apparent would now have passed to the emperor's brother maximilian but of course maximilian has come to a very sticky end hasn't he because he's gone off to be emperor in Mexico and been shot. Exactly. So actually, the title would now pass to Franz Ferdinand's father, Karl Ludwig. But Karl Ludwig is quite old and he's not in terribly good health. So when Karl Ludwig dies seven years later, Franz Ferdinand, the emperor's nephew,
儿子。在其他情况下，王位继承人的角色现在应该传给皇帝的弟弟马克西米利安，但马克西米利安当然已经落得一个非常悲惨的下场，不是吗？因为他去墨西哥当皇帝，结果被枪杀了。没错。所以实际上，头衔现在应该传给弗朗茨·斐迪南的父亲卡尔·路德维希。但卡尔·路德维希年纪很大，健康状况也不太好。所以当卡尔·路德维希七年后去世时，皇帝的侄子弗朗茨·斐迪南，
is unexpectedly the heir to the Austrian throne and will inherit the reigns of this extraordinary multinational dynastic empire. Well, the description is usually ramshackle. Yes. Do you think it's ramshackle? This is a really thorny kind of historical question. We know that Austria-Hungary broke up, obviously, at the end of the First World War. And so I think for a long time, there was a lot of historical question. We know that Austria-Hungary broke up, obviously, at the end of the First World War. And so I think for a long time, there was a lot of back projection. And the classic thing that historians would say about it is it's stagnant, it's ramshackle.
意外地成为了奥地利王位的继承人，并将继承这个非凡的跨国王朝帝国的统治权。嗯，描述通常是“破烂不堪”。是的。你认为它破烂不堪吗？这是一个非常棘手的历史问题。我们知道奥匈帝国在第一次世界大战结束时显然解体了。所以我认为长期以来，有很多事后投射。历史学家对它的经典评价是：它停滞不前，它破烂不堪。
I mean, they always use the word sclerotic and, you know, all this kind of stuff. So Tim Butcher in The Trigger, which we've been citing a lot he quotes from the uh baedeker to the empire of 1905 and in this the baedeker points out that in in some areas of the empire people will drive on the right and some people drive on the left and then butch says it did not say what happened when the two driving styles collided and i guess that that is always the risk, isn't it? With not just Austria and Hungary, but also all the various constituent parts who are not given equal status with Austria and Hungary, that they all have different interests. And occasionally they're going to come into collision with each other.
我的意思是，他们总是用“硬化”这个词，你知道，所有这些东西。所以蒂姆·布彻在《导火索》（The Trigger）中，我们引用了很多次，他引用了1905年的《贝德克尔帝国指南》。在这本书中，贝德克尔指出，在帝国的一些地区，人们靠右行驶，而有些人靠左行驶。然后布彻说，它没有说当这两种驾驶风格碰撞时会发生什么。我想这总是风险所在，不是吗？不仅是奥地利和匈牙利，还有所有没有获得与奥地利和匈牙利同等地位的组成部分，它们都有不同的利益。偶尔它们会发生碰撞。
Well, occasionally, I mean, all the time. So just to give people a sense of some of the nationalities, we're talking about Germans, Czechs, Hungarians, Poles, Ukrainians, Italians, Romanians, Croats, Slovenes,lovenes slovaks serbs and so on and so on we haven't even mentioned bosnian muslims now the austrians i think it's fair to say were generally the more liberal of the two partners the hungarians treated their nationalities issue by basically pretending it didn't exist at all but i don't think it is fair to say that austria is a basket case or that it is doomed by nationalism first of all economically it's actually
嗯，偶尔，我的意思是，一直都在发生。所以为了让大家了解一些民族，我们谈论的是德国人、捷克人、匈牙利人、波兰人、乌克兰人、意大利人、罗马尼亚人、克罗地亚人、斯洛文尼亚人、斯洛伐克人、塞尔维亚人等等。我们甚至还没提到波斯尼亚穆斯林。我认为可以公平地说，奥地利人通常是两个伙伴中比较自由的一个。匈牙利人处理民族问题的方式基本上是假装它根本不存在。但我不认为说奥地利是一个烂摊子或者它注定会被民族主义毁灭是公平的。首先，从经济上讲，它实际上
reasonably successful you've got a big customs union integrated markets transport network factories all of this stuff it's actually booming isn't it at this period in the years before the first world war the austria hungarian economy is growing by about five percent a year my god tom i mean we give a lot for that right what would we give for that today there actually isn't that much political violence there is some of course but it's not as bad as the political violence for example in russia and you could argue it's not as bad as the threat of political violence in ireland yeah for example of course there are a lot of nationalists and all these different national groups are demanding more privileges and more airtime, more money and all that stuff, more patronage. But radical nationalists calling for violent separation are actually pretty rare.
相当成功。你有一个巨大的关税同盟、统一的市场、交通网络、工厂，所有这些东西。它实际上正在蓬勃发展，不是吗？在第一次世界大战前的几年里，奥匈帝国的经济每年增长约5%。天哪，汤姆，我的意思是，我们今天会为那个付出很多，对吧？今天我们能得到什么？实际上并没有那么多的政治暴力。当然有一些，但并不像俄罗斯的政治暴力那么严重，你也可以说它不像爱尔兰的政治暴力威胁那么严重。是的，当然有很多民族主义者，所有这些不同的民族群体都在要求更多的特权、更多的曝光率、更多的金钱和所有这些东西，更多的恩惠。但呼吁暴力分离的激进民族主义者实际上非常罕见。
Even most nationalist politicians recognize they can probably get more by being in the empire and moaning about it than they would by breaking away well i mean it's interesting definitely when it collapses there are then a lot of nationalists who say oh we've made a mistake i mean particularly by the 30s i wish we were back with the hapsburgs because of course if the hapsburg empire breaks up it is pretty obvious there will be a lot of fighting yeah about who inherits which bits yeah and where they draw the um borders now all of that said of course it's not perfect for one thing the court is incredibly conservative i often wonder whether it's a it's a classic case of kind of overcompensating because they have been on the retreat and because they have lost some of their
即使大多数民族主义政治家也认识到，留在帝国并抱怨它，可能比分裂出去能得到更多。嗯，我的意思是，这很有趣。当它崩溃时，确实有很多民族主义者说，哦，我们犯了一个错误。我的意思是，特别是在30年代，我希望我们能回到哈布斯堡王朝。因为当然，如果哈布斯堡帝国解体，很明显会有很多关于谁继承哪一部分的争斗，以及他们在哪里划定边界。现在，话虽如此，它当然并不完美。首先，宫廷极其保守。我经常怀疑这是否是一种过度补偿的典型案例，因为他们一直在撤退，因为他们失去了一些
former power and so they're trying much too hard to pretend that nothing has changed so franz joseph is pathologically conservative and hierarchical you know we laugh at george the fifth having his strict views about how you creased your trousers yeah i mean franz joseph the issue of what trousers you're wearing is an existential one yeah um he becomes a very melancholy, sort of pessimistic figure. Not least because, I mean, his son has committed suicide. His brother's been shot. His brother has been killed in Mexico. But then his wife, the most glamorous woman in Europe, Cece, Elizabeth.
以前的权力，所以他们太努力地假装什么都没有改变。所以弗朗茨·约瑟夫病态地保守和等级森严。你知道，我们嘲笑乔治五世对裤子如何折痕有严格的看法。是的，我的意思是，弗朗茨·约瑟夫关于你穿什么裤子的问题是一个存在主义的问题。是的，他变成了一个非常忧郁、悲观的人物。不仅因为他的儿子自杀了，他的弟弟在墨西哥被枪杀。而且他的妻子，欧洲最迷人的女人，茜茜公主，伊丽莎白。
The Diana. She's the Diana with knobs on of her era. She was murdered on Lake Geneva by an Italian anarchist in 1898. So from that point onwards, Franz Joseph becomes very lonely and sad and kind of reclusive. So Franz Ferdinand grows up in this world. He's in the army, commissioned in the army when he's 12. He basically is steeped in the kind of the world of the Habsburg army, which is, of course, the one institution that's really holding the empire together.
她是那个时代的戴安娜。她是她那个时代戴安娜的升级版。她于1898年在日内瓦湖被一名意大利无政府主义者谋杀。所以从那时起，弗朗茨·约瑟夫变得非常孤独、悲伤和隐居。所以弗朗茨·斐迪南在这个世界中长大。他在军队里，12岁时被任命为军官。他基本上沉浸在哈布斯堡军队的世界里，这当然是真正将帝国凝聚在一起的唯一机构。
It's also, interestingly, it's an institution where the Austrian side is given a degree of primacy because everyone is expected to speak German, aren't they? Yeah, which the Hungarians don't. And we'll come on to this. For Franz Ferdinand, the fact that the Hungarians don't speak German is an unbelievable affront, absolutely intolerable.
有趣的是，这也是一个奥地利方面享有一定优先权的机构，因为每个人都被要求说德语，不是吗？是的，匈牙利人不说。我们稍后会谈到这一点。对于弗朗茨·斐迪南来说，匈牙利人不说德语是一个令人难以置信的侮辱，绝对无法容忍。
So he, you know, when you look at photos of him as a young man he's always wearing very tight uniforms uh admiring his enormous mustache sort of sitting around in the officer's mess with the other papsburg officers and things and that's his milieu the problem for him is that the emperor has never recovered from the loss of his son and makes no effort whatsoever to disguise the fact that he considers franz ferdinand an absolute waste of space so that when they first met after the meiling tragedy the emperor treated franz ferdinand really like dirt franz ferdinand said afterwards i've never been treated so coldly before the mere sight of me seems to awaken
所以，你知道，当你看到他年轻时的照片时，他总是穿着非常紧身的制服，欣赏他巨大的胡子，和其他哈布斯堡军官坐在军官食堂里，这就是他的环境。对他来说，问题在于皇帝从未从失去儿子的痛苦中恢复过来，并且毫不掩饰他认为弗朗茨·斐迪南完全是浪费空间的事实。所以当他们在梅耶林悲剧后第一次见面时，皇帝对待弗朗茨·斐迪南真的像对待垃圾一样。弗朗茨·斐迪南后来感叹：“我从未受到过如此冷遇。仅仅看到我似乎就会唤起
unpleasant memories it's like denethor mourning boromir it totally is thing faramir yeah no absolutely there was no warmth between them and never is the sad thing is that franz ferdinand he clearly admired franz joseph enormously was very respectful of him never spoke out of turn, never criticized him, never betrayed a hint of his frustration. And yet the emperor continued to treat him with sort of cold indifference. And do you think this is why he's so rude to other people? So kind of short with other people? Franz Ferdinand is famously a very short-tempered man. And clearly a lot of this is, I think, because he's a very frustrated man.
不愉快的记忆。”这就像德内梭尔哀悼博罗米尔一样，完全是法拉米尔。是的，不，绝对没有。他们之间没有任何温暖，从来没有，可悲的是。弗朗茨·斐迪南显然非常钦佩弗朗茨·约瑟夫，对他非常尊重，从不乱说话，从不批评他，从不流露出一丝挫败感。然而，皇帝继续以一种冷漠的态度对待他。你认为这就是他对待其他人如此粗鲁的原因吗？对其他人那么简短？弗朗茨·斐迪南以脾气暴躁而闻名。显然，我认为这很大程度上是因为他是一个非常沮丧的人。
The round-the-world trip, for example, he's clearly curious. When you see those photos of him on the day of the assassination sarajevo where he does as you put it he looks like an austrian walrus you don't think of him as a as a sort of curious man as a as a stream trying to break its banks that's why that photograph of him in the the pharaoh's coffin is so unexpected yeah and funny it is funny so he does the round the world trip and he writes that lyrical passage about it, about how much he loved seeing new experiences
例如，环球旅行，他显然很好奇。当你看到他在萨拉热窝遇刺那天拍的那些照片时，正如你所说，他看起来像一只奥地利海象。你不会认为他是一个好奇的人，像一条试图冲破堤岸的河流。这就是为什么他在法老棺材里的那张照片如此出人意料，而且很有趣。它确实很有趣。所以他进行了环球旅行，并写下了那段抒情的段落，关于他有多喜欢看到新的经历
and learning and all this stuff. Then a year later, he fell ill with lung problems. He probably had a version of TB. Like Gavrilo Princip. And he was sent to Egypt to recuperate. That's when he poses as a mummy. But when he's away,
和学习所有这些东西。一年后，他患上了肺部疾病。他可能患有某种形式的肺结核。就像加夫里洛·普林西普一样。他被送往埃及疗养。那就是他装扮成木乃伊的时候。但当他不在的时候，
everybody thinks he's going to die and they say oh brilliant his younger brother otto is the new heir now and the emperor and everybody else treats otto as the heir and franz ferdinand knows this and he's absolutely gutted and so when he comes back and everybody's like oh no he's still alive he's really hurt i think and disappointed by this and so as um i as almost any account you read of him says, he grew into a man suspicious, morose, and violent, seeing enemies everywhere, and because of this, turning would-be friends into enemies.
每个人都认为他快要死了，他们说：“哦，太棒了，他的弟弟奥托现在是新的继承人了。”皇帝和其他所有人都把奥托当作继承人对待。弗朗茨·斐迪南知道这一点，他感到非常痛苦。所以当他回来，每个人都像“哦，不，他还活着”时，他感到非常受伤和失望。所以，正如你读到的关于他的几乎每一份记录所说，他成长为一个多疑、阴郁、暴力的人，到处寻找敌人，正因为如此，他把潜在的朋友变成了敌人。
He also has the same, I mean, to his credit, Tom, he has the same view of the human condition as I do. Yes, I saw this. So I always assume that everyone I meet is a rogue until the contrary is proved. It's exactly what I think. Yeah. Yeah, absolutely what i think incredible so so we've already had captain bentin as a kind of analog to you from the 19th century history and now we've got franz
他也有同样的，我的意思是，值得称赞的是，汤姆，他对人类状况的看法和我一样。是的，我看到了。所以我总是假设我遇到的每个人都是流氓，直到证明相反。这正是我所想的。是的，绝对是我所想的。不可思议。所以我们已经有了本廷船长作为你19世纪历史的类比，现在我们有了弗朗茨。
my dream dinner party is captain bentin and franz ferdinand tom no no question he's very hot-tempered he's exceptionally rude something else i I admire in a... So he's rude to servants. I don't approve of that, Tom, to be fair. I'm very polite to assets. But when it comes to birds, I mean, he's terrible to birds, isn't he? You wouldn't want to be a bird with him when he's got his gun. You wouldn't. Sorry, Tom, I've shamed myself by taking a mouthful of cake. Theo is absolutely livid. So I don't approve of shooting birds.
我梦想的晚宴嘉宾是本廷船长和弗朗茨·斐迪南，汤姆。毫无疑问。他脾气非常暴躁，异常粗鲁，这是我钦佩的另一件事……所以他对仆人很粗鲁。说实话，汤姆，我不赞成那样。我对资产非常礼貌。但说到鸟类，我的意思是，他对鸟类很糟糕，不是吗？当他拿着枪时，你不会想成为一只鸟。你不会。抱歉，汤姆，我因为吃了一口蛋糕而感到羞愧。西奥非常愤怒。所以我不赞成射杀鸟类。
Have you seen how many he shot in his life? So 272,511 game kills, 5,000 of which were deer. So I'm assuming all the rest were birds. Have you seen how many he shot? I have. So 272,511 game kills, 5,000 of which were deer. So I'm assuming all the rest were birds. 100,000 trophies were on exhibit at his bohemian castle.
你见过他一生中射杀了多少吗？272,511只猎物，其中5,000只是鹿。所以我假设其余的都是鸟。你见过他射杀了多少吗？我见过。272,511只猎物，其中5,000只是鹿。所以我假设其余的都是鸟。100,000个战利品在他的波希米亚城堡展出。
Yeah. In one day's hunt alone, he shot 2,140 game birds and animals. Yeah. Astonishing. Different times, Tom. And on his world tour,
是的。仅在一天狩猎中，他就射杀了2,140只猎鸟和动物。是的。令人震惊。不同的时代，汤姆。在他的环球旅行中，
I mean, it's all very well you going on about, oh, he's out there being a hippie and discovering himself. No. elephants emus kangaroos koalas monkeys tigers grizzly bears and when he went to yellowstone park and was kind of bored by the geezers yeah you know he he solved the problem of his boredom but by shooting porcupines and squirrels he's very keen to take on a bison no but to be fair to him he's a very good shot yeah fine well that's a reassurance for the birds isn't it yeah and actually okay i think a lot of listeners at
我的意思是，你一直在说他像个嬉皮士一样去发现自我，这很好。不。大象、鸸鹋、袋鼠、考拉、猴子、老虎、灰熊。当他去黄石公园时，对间歇泉感到厌烦，是的，你知道，他通过射杀豪猪和松鼠解决了他的无聊问题。他非常热衷于猎杀野牛。不，但公平地说，他枪法很好。是的，好吧，这对鸟类来说是个安慰，不是吗？是的，实际上，好吧，我想很多听众在
this point be thinking thinking badly of franz ferdinand not unreasonably of course this is the age tom i know you have a bizarre fetish about this because you're very interested in the history of shooting game you were desperate to recalibrate this series and have more shooting in it i think there's already quite a lot of shooting um and there will be more shooting to come there will be so george v loves shooting yeah aristocrats love i mean this is the big thing and it's become almost industrialized so they have beaters who will basically send hundreds and hundreds of birds into the air and you shoot them all and you're right i would i would at some point like to do an episode on what's going on in britain at this point yeah just on the the case of the prosecution yeah franz
这一点上会认为弗朗茨·斐迪南很糟糕，这并不不合理。当然，这是那个时代，汤姆。我知道你对此有一种奇怪的迷恋，因为你对狩猎的历史非常感兴趣。你非常渴望重新调整这个系列，并在其中加入更多的射击内容。我认为已经有很多射击内容了，而且未来还会有更多。会有。所以乔治五世喜欢射击，是的，贵族们喜欢……我的意思是，这是一件大事，它几乎已经工业化了。所以他们有驱赶鸟的人，基本上会把成百上千只鸟赶到空中，然后你把它们全部射下来。你是对的，我确实想在某个时候做一期关于当时英国正在发生什么的事情。是的，仅就起诉书而言，弗朗茨
ferdinand being a terrible person yeah i quote the german historian michael freund a man of uninspired energy dark in appearance and emotion who radiated an aura of strangeness and cast a shadow of violence and recklessness so this is the person who you're comparing yourself to. I can see the parallels. Uncanny. They're obviously uncanny. But I mean, presumably that's not why you're sticking up for him.
斐迪南是一个糟糕的人。是的，我引用德国历史学家迈克尔·弗罗因德的话：“一个缺乏灵感、外表和情感阴暗的人，他散发出一种怪异的气息，投下了暴力和鲁莽的阴影。”所以这就是你把自己与之比较的人。我能看出相似之处。不可思议。它们显然是不可思议的。但我的意思是，大概这不是你支持他的原因。
No, because actually there is another side to Franz Ferdinand as we will see. So he might not seem the most obviously lovable character, but obviously the one thing he needs is a wife. wife. He needs a consort.
不，因为实际上弗朗茨·斐迪南还有另一面，正如我们将看到的。所以他看起来可能不是最可爱的人物，但显然他需要的是一位妻子。他需要一位配偶。
Now, Franz Ferdinand doesn't seem to have been a great man for the ladies. He is always complaining, basically, that women are stalking him and trying to marry him. So when he went to Britain in the mid 1890s, he said he'd had an absolutely terrible time with all these sort of posh women being pushed at him. Hello, Franzi. Yeah. He said the designated fiancées moved about in a great herd and showed worrisome levels of persistence. But of course, if there were British families who were pushing their daughters forward,
现在，弗朗茨·斐迪南似乎不是一个伟大的女性崇拜者。他总是抱怨，基本上，女性在跟踪他并试图嫁给他。所以当他在19世纪90年代中期去英国时，他说他与所有这些被推给他的时髦女性在一起度过了一段绝对糟糕的时光。你好，弗兰齐。是的。他说指定的未婚妻们成群结队地走动，表现出令人担忧的坚持。但当然，如果有英国家庭在推销他们的女儿，
they were wasting their time because there was a list and they were not on it. So in 1825, something called the hapsburg house law had been drawn up and every head of the house of hapsburg was bound by this law your bride had to be a catholic but also there was a list of families from which this bride could come so aristocratic 15 princely houses hoursburg esterhazy caven hula lobowitz, Metternich and so on. I hope you enjoy that Austrian accent Tom. And there were 33 houses that were not part of the monarchy but were sufficiently aristocratic. So the Fugger-Babenhausens, the Hohenlohrs, the House of Turm and Taxis and so on and so forth.
他们是在浪费时间，因为有一份名单，而她们不在名单上。所以1825年，制定了所谓的《哈布斯堡家族法》，每一位哈布斯堡家族的族长都受此法律约束。你的新娘必须是天主教徒，而且还有一份名单，新娘必须来自这些家族。所以是贵族，15个王室家族：哈布斯堡、埃斯特哈齐、卡文胡拉、洛布科维茨、梅特涅等等。希望你喜欢那个奥地利口音，汤姆。还有33个家族不属于君主制，但足够高贵。比如富格尔-巴本豪森家族、霍恩洛厄家族、图恩和塔克西斯家族等等。
So this is Franz Ferdinand's list. He regards this list with total contempt which is interesting because he's such a conservative person in other respects but he said to he wrote to a woman friend of his and he said um the women who are being offered to me are all and i quote chicks of 17 and 18 each one uglier than the last right so so he's gallant as well as as well as charming to servants. Yes. So he's not happy with the list. Now, one of his relatives, who was called Archduchess Isabella, decided that she would bag him for one of her daughters. A guy called Gordon Brookshepard, who's written a lot about Austrian history,
所以这是弗朗茨·斐迪南的名单。他以完全蔑视的态度看待这份名单，这很有趣，因为他在其他方面是一个如此保守的人。但他对一位女性朋友写道，他说：“嗯，提供给我的女性都是，我引用，17和18岁的小鸡，一个比一个丑。”好吧，所以他既勇敢又对仆人很有魅力。是的。所以他对名单不满意。现在，他的一位亲戚，名叫伊莎贝拉大公夫人，决定要把他留给她的一个女儿。一个叫戈登·布鲁克谢帕德的人，他写了很多关于奥地利历史的书，
describes her as an immensely built and immensely ambitious woman. She's always inviting him to her house at Pressburg. And he's very keen to go, isn't at pressburg and he's very keen to go isn't he yeah he's very keen to go and he keeps going back yeah and she's like she is obviously this is fantastic after my daughters this is absolutely splendid he's dancing my daughters again having dinner telling anecdotes about shooting birds all is well and then an absolute disaster in april 1899 they have a tennis party. Franz Ferdinand goes and he's in great form.
形容她是一个身材魁梧且野心勃勃的女人。她总是邀请他去她在普雷斯堡的家。他非常热衷于去，不是吗？在普雷斯堡，他非常热衷于去，是的，他非常热衷于去，而且他不断地回去。是的，她就像，这显然太棒了，追求我的女儿们，这绝对太棒了。他再次和我的女儿们跳舞，共进晚餐，讲述关于射杀鸟类的轶事，一切都很顺利。然后，1899年4月发生了一场绝对的灾难，他们举行了一场网球派对。弗朗茨·斐迪南去了，状态很好。
And then he leaves and he leaves his watch behind. I'm assuming it's a pocket watch rather than a wristwatch because it's got a locket attached to it. It would be, wouldn't it? And a servant finds it and takes it to the Archduchess Isabella and says, found Franz Ferdinand's watch. Isabella opens the locket, looking forward to seeing which of her
然后他离开了，把他的手表落下了。我假设这是一块怀表而不是手表，因为它上面挂着一个小盒。应该是，不是吗？一个仆人发现了它，把它带给伊莎贝拉大公夫人，说：“发现了弗朗茨·斐迪南的手表。”伊莎贝拉打开小盒，期待着看到是她的哪一个
daughters it is and horror of horrors the picture in the locket is of a lady in waiting so this is sophie countess sophie chotec von chotkova and vognin and sophie choteek has been attached for a few years to Archduchess Isabella's house. She is 27 years old. Franz Ferdinand is 37. They're both mature and very serious people. Sophie Chotek is an aristocrat. Her family had been barons in Bohemia since 1556. They've been counts of the Empire since 1745.
女儿，结果恐怖的是，小盒里的照片是一位侍女。这就是索菲，索菲·乔泰克·冯·乔特科娃和沃格宁伯爵夫人。索菲·乔泰克已经在伊莎贝拉大公夫人的家里待了几年了。她27岁。弗朗茨·斐迪南37岁。他们都是成熟且非常严肃的人。索菲·乔泰克是贵族。她的家族自1556年以来一直是波希米亚的男爵。自1745年以来，他们一直是帝国的伯爵。
But Tom, she is not on the list. And so that's why she ranks as a lady-in-waiting. Exactly. And so she's ineligible. Archduchess Isabella is outraged. So she kicks Sophie out of the house, immediately reports this to the Emperor.
但汤姆，她不在名单上。所以这就是为什么她被列为侍女。没错。所以她没有资格。伊莎贝拉大公夫人被激怒了。所以她把索菲赶出了家门，并立即向皇帝报告了这件事。
The Emperor says to Franz Ferdinand, what are you thinking? She's not on the list you can have the chotech or you can have the crown but you cannot have both and so again for british people yeah familiar with our own beloved monarchy yeah i mean again the echoes are they are very clear except the difference i think tom because if franz joseph is is elizabeth's second oh right yes then um i mean there is a definite element of Charles and Camilla here, isn't there? Yeah, I hadn't thought of that, Tom.
皇帝对弗朗茨·斐迪南说：“你在想什么？她不在名单上。你可以选择乔泰克，也可以选择王冠，但你不能两者兼得。”所以，对于英国人来说，是的，熟悉我们自己心爱的君主制，我的意思是，回声非常清晰。除了区别，我认为汤姆，因为如果弗朗茨·约瑟夫是伊丽莎白二世，哦，对了，是的，那么，我的意思是，这里肯定有查尔斯和卡米拉的成分，不是吗？是的，我没想到这一点，汤姆。
You know, I mean, really, it's a great love story. He's pledged to Camilla. You got the honours list in mind again, Tom. Yeah, always. If I don't get the order of the fleece from Edward Habsburg. But I mean, he seems to have loved Sophie for for the same reason that charles seems so keen on camilla that she calms him down and makes him feel happy she does and it's probably the only person who makes him feel happy as far as i think that's absolutely right everybody says sophie chodek
你知道，我的意思是，真的，这是一个伟大的爱情故事。他向卡米拉承诺了。你又想到了荣誉名单，汤姆。是的，总是。如果我没有从爱德华·哈布斯堡那里得到金羊毛勋章。但我的意思是，他似乎爱索菲的原因和查尔斯似乎对卡米拉如此热衷的原因一样，她让他平静下来，让他感到快乐。她确实做到了，而且她可能是唯一让他感到快乐的人，就我所知。我认为这绝对正确。每个人都说索菲·乔泰克
she is a really decent sensible she's polite she's tactful she is nice so basically everything he isn't yeah and she's great for him now Franz Joseph the emperor just is dead against this they get the cardinal archbishop of Vienna he gets all the relatives everybody to gang up on Franz Ferdinand and say dropper you know terrible decision Franz Ferdinand goes absolutely ballistic and he shouts at them and he says um your stupid marriage laws are the reason that half of the children in our family are idiots or epileptics which obviously doesn't go well yeah he's agreeing with james joyce who described the hapsburgs as the most physically corrupt royal family in europe so franz ferdinand might well have agreed with you franz ferdinand just throws this you know a massive wobbly i must marry her and
她是一个非常正派、明智的人，她礼貌、圆滑、善良。所以基本上他所缺乏的一切，她都有。是的，她对他很好。现在，皇帝弗朗茨·约瑟夫坚决反对这一点。他让维也纳的红衣主教大主教，让所有的亲戚，每个人都联合起来反对弗朗茨·斐迪南，说：“放弃吧，你知道，这是个可怕的决定。”弗朗茨·斐迪南彻底崩溃了，他对着他们大喊大叫，他说：“你们愚蠢的婚姻法是我们家族中一半的孩子是白痴或癫痫患者的原因。”这显然没有起到好作用。是的，他同意詹姆斯·乔伊斯的观点，他形容哈布斯堡家族是欧洲身体最腐败的王室。所以弗朗茨·斐迪南很可能同意你的观点。弗朗茨·斐迪南只是发了一通脾气：“我必须娶她，而且……”
eventually the emperor gives in franz ferdinand sticks to his guns the emperor to a degree right right so the emperor gives in and he says fine you marry her but here is the deal i will raise her to a duchess duchess of hohenberg but if you think she will ever be empress, be queen of Hungary and empress of Austria, and that your children will be emperors of Austria, you know, you can forget about it. That is the deal. It will have to be a morganatic marriage where she will never have the same status as you, and neither will the children. Now, that is a big thing to ask of somebody.
最终皇帝让步了。弗朗茨·斐迪南坚持自己的立场，皇帝在一定程度上……是的，皇帝让步了，他说：“好吧，你娶她，但这是交易：我会把她提升为霍恩贝格公爵夫人。但如果你认为她会成为皇后，成为匈牙利女王和奥地利皇后，并且你的孩子会成为奥地利皇帝，你知道，你可以忘了它。”这就是交易。这必须是一场贵贱通婚，她永远不会拥有和你一样的地位，孩子们也不会。现在，这对某人来说是一个很大的要求。
You will be emperor, but your children never will and it's a sign of how serious franz ferdinand is about sophie that he says fine that's what i have to do i'll do it and so it is that on the 28th of june remember the date 28th of june 1900 in the secret council chamber at the hofburg palace in vienna franz j Franz Joseph the Emperor and all 15 archdukes of the Habsburg house go out on this kind of dais. He reads out the terms. Franz Ferdinand has to publicly agree to the terms. His wife and children will never have equal status to him. And then he signs a declaration of renunciation, a oath that is it legally you know my kids will not inherit a gutting a galling thing for him a humiliating yeah and terrible humiliations
你将成为皇帝，但你的孩子永远不会。弗朗茨·斐迪南对索菲的认真程度表明，他说：“好吧，如果我必须这样做，我会做的。”所以，在1900年6月28日——记住这个日期，6月28日——在维也纳霍夫堡宫的秘密会议厅里，皇帝弗朗茨·约瑟夫和哈布斯堡家族的所有15位大公都走上了这个讲台。他宣读了条款。弗朗茨·斐迪南必须公开同意这些条款。他的妻子和孩子永远不会拥有与他平等的地位。然后他签署了一份放弃声明，一份誓言，即在法律上，你知道，我的孩子不会继承。对他来说，这是一件令人痛苦、屈辱的事情，是的，可怕的屈辱
will be visited on sophie when they awful awful so we'll come to them just a sec three days later they go and they get married they get married at a hapsburg castle in bohemia the emperor doesn't go none of the archdukes go. None of the uncles, brothers, and cousins of Franz Ferdinand. Franz Ferdinand is the only archduke at his own wedding. No cardinals go, no bishops go. A big deal for the Habsburgs, the ultra-Catholic family of kind of dynastic Europe. It's just an ordinary parish priest who officiates. So basically they have this sort of private wedding and then they go to his castle at Conopista with the one with all the trophies of birds and stuff.
将降临在索菲身上，当他们……太可怕了。所以我们稍后再谈。三天后，他们去结婚了。他们在波希米亚的一座哈布斯堡城堡结婚。皇帝没有去，大公们都没有去。弗朗茨·斐迪南的叔叔、兄弟和堂兄弟都没有去。弗朗茨·斐迪南是他自己婚礼上唯一的大公。没有红衣主教去，没有主教去。对于哈布斯堡家族，这个王朝欧洲超天主教的家族来说，这是一件大事。只有一位普通的教区牧师主持。所以基本上他们举行了这种私人婚礼，然后他们去了他在科诺皮什特的城堡，就是那个有很多鸟类战利品之类的城堡。
And flowers as well. He's a big gardener, isn't he? He is. Again, like Charles. The honeymoon they spend walking in the garden and they call it the upper stations of the cross because they both feel completely embattled and humiliated by the terrible treatment by the rest of his family. And actually, as you said said it doesn't get any better
还有花。他是个大园丁，不是吗？他是。同样，像查尔斯一样。他们把蜜月花在花园里散步，他们称之为“苦路十四站”，因为他们都感到被他家族其他成员的可怕对待所包围和羞辱。而且，正如你所说，情况并没有好转。
the guy who ran the court yeah imperial chamberlain count montenuovo was himself the product of a morganatic marriage from napoleon yeah some more on napoleon's wives and somebody or something like this and he is really bitter that sophie has got above her station. And he, during the attempt to sort of discredit her, he'd circulated photos of her that he had retouched to make her look older and uglier than she was. Yeah, I remember the royal family touching up photos. Yeah. I heard of.
管理宫廷的那个人，是的，帝国侍从长蒙泰努沃伯爵，他本人就是拿破仑那场贵庶通婚的产物，关于拿破仑的妻子们还有其他一些事，他真的对索菲地位的提升感到愤愤不平。在试图抹黑她的过程中，他散布了她的照片，并进行了修图，让她看起来比实际年龄更老、更丑。是的，我记得皇室成员会修饰照片。是的，我听说过。
So here's how it works. From this point onwards, when they go to court functions, when they all file him, Franz Ferdinand has to walk on his own as if he's not married everybody else comes in and she has to come in last so all the other archduchesses and things come in she has to come in last on her own for everyone to kind of she can't sit in the hapsburg box she can't sit next to him at the opera she can't use the carriage the official carriage
事情是这样的。从这一点开始，当他们参加宫廷活动时，当他们排队入场时，弗朗茨·斐迪南必须独自一人走，就好像他没有结婚一样，其他人都要进来，而她必须最后进来，所以所有其他的女大公之类的人都进来了，她必须最后独自一人进来，让每个人都……她不能坐在哈布斯堡家族的包厢里，她不能在歌剧院坐在他旁边，她不能使用马车，那辆官方马车。
if a visiting monarch comes to have an official dinner and Franz Ferdinand is there as invited, the seat next to him for his consort is left empty as a sign and she is forced to sit down kind of below the salt with the other people of her status. I think the glorious thing about her is that she doesn't seem to show her bitterness about this. She maintains her good humor which is what franz ferdinand wants and needs from her totally yeah they're incredibly happy as a couple they're completely devoted they have three children
如果有来访的君主参加正式晚宴，而弗朗茨·斐迪南也在受邀之列，他配偶的座位必须空着，作为一种标志，她被迫坐在地位较低的人群中。我认为她最了不起的地方在于，她似乎并没有表现出对这一切的怨恨。她保持着良好的幽默感，而这正是弗朗茨·斐迪南从她身上完全想要和需要的，是的，他们作为夫妻非常幸福，他们完全忠诚于彼此，他们有三个孩子。
sophie maximilian and ernst will come on to the children a little bit later they basically spend most of their time at this castle which is now the czech republic called konopista every morning he goes out and he assaults the local birds then in the afternoons they spend their time gardening and then the evenings he's like playing drafts with the kids and all that kind of thing and they are by the standards of their age i.e with a lot of hunting they are a really model devoted happy so they have a daughter don't they and two sons two sons exactly neither of of whom are going to inherit the throne to inherit the throne and actually the thing about the gardening franz fernand lots of people won't know this he is a great gardener he's one of europe's great gardeners so conor pister and his other castle archdetton he creates these amazing rose
索菲、马克西米利安和恩斯特，我们稍后再谈孩子们，他们基本上大部分时间都待在这个现在属于捷克共和国的城堡里，叫科诺皮什切，每天早上他都会出去袭击当地的鸟类，然后下午他们花时间园艺，晚上他会和孩子们玩跳棋之类的东西，按照他们那个时代的标准，也就是有很多狩猎活动，他们真的是一对模范、忠诚、幸福的夫妻，他们有一个女儿，对吧，还有两个儿子，两个儿子，没错，他们两个都不会继承王位，继承王位，其实关于园艺的事，弗朗茨·斐迪南，很多人不知道这一点，他是一位伟大的园艺家，他是欧洲最伟大的园艺家之一，所以科诺皮什切和他另一个城堡阿尔特顿，他创造了这些令人惊叹的玫瑰。
gardens people say the best rose gardens in Central Europe. And he gets all these lovely messages about his. Would you like me to read you a message about his? Yeah. So here we go. This is from somebody who'd come to stay at his house. Again, thank you from my heart for the precious hours I was able to spend with you in Klingsor's Magic Garden.
花园，人们说这是中欧最好的玫瑰园。他收到了所有关于他的可爱信息。你想让我读一条关于他的信息吗？好的。那么我们开始吧。这是来自一位曾在他家住过的人。再次衷心感谢您，让我能与您在克林格索尔的魔法花园中度过宝贵的时光。
That's a Wagner reference. It's a Wagner reference. I admire the organizational mastery and the fine color sense which show through in your landscaping. Glorious weather here. The roses in my rose garden are nearly all in bloom. Rhododendrons still flowering in spite of three weeks rain. So which tender-hearted, sensitive, green-fingered,
那是瓦格纳的典故。那是瓦格纳的典故。我钦佩您在景观设计中展现出的组织大师风范和细腻的色彩感。这里天气很好。我玫瑰园里的玫瑰几乎都开了。尽管下了三周的雨，杜鹃花仍在盛开。那么，这位心地柔软、敏感、有园艺天赋、
lovable-sounding person was that? It's our old friend, the Kaiser. Oh, bless him. The Kaiser. In his gardening shoes. So the Kaiser sent that message to Franz Ferdinand. Oh, Tom, the tragedy, he sent it two weeks before Franz Ferdinand was murdered in Sarajevo. And it just goes to prove what I've always said about this whole story about 20th century European history. The real victim is, of course, the Kaiser. And on that bombshell, I think we should take a break.
听起来很可爱的人是谁呢？是我们老朋友，德皇。哦，保佑他。德皇。穿着他的园艺鞋。所以德皇给弗朗茨·斐迪南发了那条信息。哦，汤姆，悲剧的是，他在弗朗茨·斐迪南在萨拉热窝被暗杀前两周发出的。这恰恰证明了我一直以来对整个20世纪欧洲历史故事的看法。真正的受害者当然是德皇。带着这个重磅炸弹，我想我们应该休息一下。
And when we come back, we will continue looking at the life of Franz Ferdinand. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
当我们回来时，我们将继续审视弗朗茨·斐迪南的生活。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是您每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉您这一切是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to the rest of history. I have a mouthful of Viennese cake. And the reason for that is that Theo has just been telling off me and you, Dominic.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《剩下的就是历史》。我嘴里塞满了维也纳蛋糕。原因就是西奥刚刚在责备我和你，多米尼克。
For eating cake during the recording. For eating cake during the recording. So being very naughty. He's looking very cross. Glaring at us. But I've now finished eating the cake. There you go. And I'm going to begin with a quote.
因为在录音时吃蛋糕。因为在录音时吃蛋糕。所以表现得很淘气。他看起来很生气。瞪着我们。但我现在已经吃完蛋糕了。好了。我要从一段引语开始。
Oh, great, Tom. So this is from Edward Crankshaw. You've written down, I don't know who he is. I'm assuming a historian. He wrote a book called The Fall of the House of Habsburg. Right. Brilliant. Great title.
哦，太棒了，汤姆。这是爱德华·克兰克肖写的。你写下来了，我不知道他是谁。我假设是一位历史学家。他写了一本书叫《哈布斯堡王朝的衰落》。对。太棒了。很棒的标题。
There was more to Franz Ferdinand than his hunting in his rose gardens. He was a bitterly frustrated man, heir to a great empire, who saw his inheritance crumbling away from mismanagement and neglect. So no point of comparison there with Prince Charles. No, right. So this thing about there being more to Franz Ferdinand. Franz Ferdinand is not just doing his roses and talking to Sophie and shooting birds. He is also increasingly interested in politics and the future of the empire.
弗朗茨·斐迪南不仅仅是狩猎和打理玫瑰园。他是一个极其沮丧的人，作为伟大帝国的继承人，他眼睁睁看着自己的遗产因管理不善和忽视而分崩离析。所以这和查尔斯王子没有可比性。不，对。所以关于弗朗茨·斐迪南不仅仅是这些。弗朗茨·斐迪南不仅仅是在打理他的玫瑰、和索菲聊天以及射杀鸟类。他同时也越来越关注政治和帝国的未来。
So we said at the beginning, of course, everyone knows now the austro-hungarian empire did not last and the consequence was a very fragmented central europe and southeastern europe and a lot of blood would flow and so the question has always been could the empire have survived franz ferdinand gives this a lot of thought so can i ask you just before you start on saying what his plans for the empire are, is your take on him and his plans that if he had not been killed in Sarajevo, if he had survived to become emperor, that the Austro-Hungarian empire would have had a good chance of cohering and sticking together? It had a chance. Whether it's a good chance is impossible to say.
所以我们开头说了，当然，现在每个人都知道奥匈帝国没有持续下去，后果是一个非常碎片化的中欧和东南欧，会有很多血流成河，所以问题一直都是，帝国本可以幸存吗？弗朗茨·斐迪南对此进行了很多思考，所以在我开始说他为帝国制定的计划之前，我可以问你吗，你对他和他的计划的看法是，如果他没有在萨拉热窝被杀，如果他幸存下来成为皇帝，奥匈帝国会有很好的机会凝聚在一起吗？它有机会。至于是不是很好的机会，无法断言。
But the idea that it had to fragment fragment and we can both think straight away of another multinational kingdom that has endured because we're both from it yeah the united kingdom so some multinational realms did survive i mean the russian federation is still going and it has a lot of people of different religions different nationalities and languages So it's not impossible to imagine a Habsburg empire that is not involved in war continuing. Maybe it loses bits. But it just, it heightens the sense of jeopardy, doesn't it? If, if we have a sense of Franz Ferdinand as a serious reformer, which he undoubtedly is, he undoubtedly is a serious reformer. By the mid-1900s, he's really thinking about this seriously. It's obvious Franz Joseph is not going to live forever and that he, Franz Ferdinand, will take over. The great trend of the day, which
但认为它必然会碎片化，我们俩立刻就能想到另一个多元民族王国，因为它幸存了下来，因为我们俩都来自那里，是的，联合王国，所以一些多元民族王国确实幸存了下来，我的意思是俄罗斯联邦现在还在运行，它有很多不同宗教、不同民族和语言的人，所以想象一个不卷入战争的哈布斯堡帝国继续存在并非不可能。也许它会失去一些部分。但这只是加剧了危险感，不是吗？如果我们认为弗朗茨·斐迪南是一位严肃的改革者，他无疑是，他无疑是一位严肃的改革者。到1900年代中期，他真的在认真考虑这个问题。弗朗茨·约瑟夫显然不会长生不老，而他，弗朗茨·斐迪南，将会接手。当时的大趋势，
we talked about in our Rise of the Nazis podcasts, is for a kind of populist pan-Germanism. So there's a guy called Georg Ritter von Schönerer, who's the guy who invented… The Hitler salute. The Hitler salute, Heil, the label Fuhrer, who's the guy who invented the Hitler salute, Heil, the label Führer, all that stuff. So he is saying we need to reorient towards Protestant Germany. You know, Germany for the Germans, a greater Germandom. Franz Ferdinand makes it very clear he absolutely despises this way of thinking.
我们在《纳粹的崛起》播客中谈到过，是一种民粹主义的泛德意志主义。有一个叫格奥尔格·里特·冯·舍内勒的人，他是发明……希特勒礼的人。希特勒礼，希特勒万岁，元首标签，他是发明希特勒礼、希特勒万岁、元首标签以及所有这些东西的人。所以他主张我们需要向新教德国靠拢。你知道，德国人的德国，一个大德意志。弗朗茨·斐迪南明确表示他绝对鄙视这种思维方式。
He's very interested in all the minorities of the empire. And so this is why he oddly doesn't like the Hungarians. Exactly. Despite the fact that he's the king of the Hungarians. Because the Hungarians are very contemptuous, aren't they, of the minorities? They are. I don't want to upset our Hungarian listeners. Well, no, they've moved on. The Hungarians don't come out terribly well from this story.
他对帝国所有的少数民族都非常感兴趣。这就是为什么他奇怪地不喜欢匈牙利人。没错。尽管他是匈牙利人的国王。因为匈牙利人对少数民族非常轻蔑，不是吗？他们是。我不想惹恼我们的匈牙利听众。好吧，不，他们已经向前看了。匈牙利人在这个故事中表现得并不太好。
So Franz Ferdinand in the Belvedere Palace in Vienna, he almost sets up a kind of shadow government, makes links with nationalist politicians, national groups. So he's genuinely interested. What do the Romanian peasants under the rule of the Magyars think? What are people saying in what is now Western Ukraine, all of this stuff? Now, the Hungarians are the great obstacle to this because in the Hungarian half of the empire, they basically give their minorities no house room at all they can't vote they have very little political expression and franz ferdang decides the hungarians are basically the opposite the massive obstacle and he absolutely despises them that is a problem isn't it if you're
所以弗朗茨·斐迪南在维也纳的美景宫，他几乎建立了一个影子政府，与民族主义政治家、民族团体建立了联系。所以他是真心感兴趣的。马扎尔人统治下的罗马尼亚农民怎么想？在现在的乌克兰西部人们在说什么？所有这些。现在，匈牙利人是实现这一目标的最大障碍，因为在帝国的匈牙利部分，他们基本上不给少数民族任何立足之地，他们不能投票，他们几乎没有政治表达权，弗朗茨·斐迪南认为匈牙利人基本上是相反的，是巨大的障碍，他绝对鄙视他们，这确实是个问题，不是吗，如果你
going to become king of hungary probably the kindest thing he said about them was he said they're a bunch of mustachioed gypsies um and in fact again and again i come back to the conviction which i should go on expressing for as long as i live that the so-called decent hungarian simply does not exist and that every hungarian be he a minister a prince cardinal a tradesman a peasant a hussar or a stable boy is a revolutionary and and then he just drew a kind of line so you can put in your own words and imagine what word he was thinking of. So yeah, he absolutely despises them. And the way he wants to break their power, he thinks of two plans. And we alluded to them in our Gavrilo Princip episodes.
要成为匈牙利国王的话。他评价他们最客气的话大概是说他们是一群留着胡子的吉普赛人。事实上，我一次又一次地回到这个信念，只要我活着，我就要表达这个信念，那就是所谓的体面的匈牙利人根本不存在，每一个匈牙利人，无论是部长、亲王、红衣主教、商人、农民、轻骑兵还是马夫，都是革命者，然后他画了一条线，所以你可以用你自己的话来填补，想象他在想什么词。所以是的，他绝对鄙视他们。他想打破他们权力的那种方式，他想到了两个计划。我们在加夫里洛·普林西普的剧集中提到过它们。
One plan is that effectively, instead of it being Austria-Hungary, it will be a kind of Austria-Hungary-Yugoslavia. So the Slav bits, particularly Croatia, Bosnia, the Dalmatian coast, they will be a kingdom of their own, no longer under the thumb of the Austrians or the Hungarians. And this is the thing that is so terrifying for Serbian nationalists. Exactly. Now, the alternative, there was a Romanian professor called Aurel Popovici, and he drew up a plan for a United States of Greater Austria. So there'd be 16 states. There'd be Austria, there'd be a little Hungary,
一个计划是，实际上，它不再是奥匈帝国，而将成为一种奥匈-南斯拉夫。所以斯拉夫部分，特别是克罗地亚、波斯尼亚、达尔马提亚海岸，它们将成为自己的王国，不再受奥地利人或匈牙利人的控制。而这正是让塞尔维亚民族主义者感到恐惧的事情。没错。现在，另一种选择，有一位叫奥雷尔·波波维奇的罗马尼亚教授，他起草了一份大奥地利合众国的计划。所以会有16个州。会有奥地利，会有个小匈牙利，
there'd be Silesia, Bohemia, West Galicia, Slovenia, Transylvania, and so on and so on and so on. And the emperor would be king of all of them equally, and it would be a federation. And you could sort of see how that would work, how that would… Although the Hungarians would hate it. The Hungarians would be absolutely furious, and it would probably provoke some kind of revolt in Hungary, I would imagine. But what a great country that would be if that still existed. I mean, that would be a tremendous country.
会有西里西亚、波希米亚、西加利西亚、斯洛文尼亚、特兰西瓦尼亚等等等等。皇帝将平等地成为所有这些国家的国王，它将是一个联邦。你可以看出那会如何运作，如何……尽管匈牙利人会讨厌它。匈牙利人会非常愤怒，我想这可能会在匈牙利引发某种起义。但如果那个国家依然存在，那将是一个多么伟大的国家啊。我的意思是，那将是一个了不起的国家。
It would be like the EU. It would be like the EU, but with more… a heavier emphasis on… On chocolate. On the sort of cakes that we're eating now, Tom, I think it's fair to say. On kind of heavy coffee houses. Now, could he deliver on that? It's hard to say. What is undoubtedly true, though, is that he had a plan drawn up,
它会像欧盟。它会像欧盟，但有更多的……更强调……关于巧克力。关于我们现在吃的这种蛋糕，汤姆，我认为公平地说。关于那种沉重的咖啡馆。现在，他能实现吗？很难说。但无疑真实的是，他起草了一份计划，
ready to go for when he exceeded, when he became emperor. He would change the suffrage laws in Hungary. Of course, that was a brilliant way of breaking the power of the Hungarian gentry who are his opponents. If he says, actually, everybody in the Hungarian half can now vote. So that would include Romanians. That would include all the Transylvanian peasants and whatnot. Three million Croats, for example, can vote. He's an improbable kind of enthusiast for broadening the franchise, isn't he?
准备好在他继位、成为皇帝时实施。他会改变匈牙利的选举法。当然，这是打破他对手——匈牙利绅士权力的绝妙方法。如果他说，实际上，匈牙利部分的每个人现在都可以投票。那将包括罗马尼亚人。那将包括所有的特兰西瓦尼亚农民等等。例如，三百万克罗地亚人可以投票。他是一个不太可能的扩大选举权的狂热者，不是吗？
He is. His other big thing, which we talked about in the first half very briefly, is he's infuriated that the Hungarians want to use their own language in their bit of the army because actually the law is you can only really have one language in the army and that should be german the language of the dynasty that should be the glue that holds the empire together that basically everybody's second language is german and that's the language of war so he's fighting the hungarians all the time about this language issue. And yet the irony is Franz Ferdinand, the one thing he never wants to do is to use that army.
他是。他的另一件大事，我们在前半部分简要谈过，是他对匈牙利人想在军队中使用他们自己的语言感到愤怒，因为实际上法律规定军队中只能真正使用一种语言，那应该是德语，王朝的语言，那应该是维系帝国的粘合剂，基本上每个人的第二语言都是德语，那是战争的语言，所以他一直在为语言问题与匈牙利人斗争。然而讽刺的是，弗朗茨·斐迪南唯一不想做的事就是使用那支军队。
And this is where Serbian intelligence, the black hand, were dead wrong. Franz Ferdinand is not the leader of the war party. The one thing he stands for more than anything else is no war and especially no war with serbia yeah it's i mean it's such a a kind of tragic irony isn't it that the serbs end up killing the one man who was holding the military establishment back from and particularly one figure in particular isn't there yeah who is franz conrad uh von herzendorf and um he is another very romantic figure he's yeah so he has a great crush on another man's wife yeah and he's endlessly writing letters to her isn't he which he's then too embarrassed to send three thousand
这就是塞尔维亚情报机构，“黑手党”，完全搞错的地方。弗朗茨·斐迪南不是战争派的领袖。他最坚持的一件事就是不打仗，尤其是不要和塞尔维亚打仗。是的，我的意思是，这真是一种悲剧性的讽刺，不是吗？塞尔维亚人最终杀死了唯一一个阻止军事机构的人，特别是有一个特定的人物，不是吗？是的，他是弗朗茨·康拉德·冯·赫岑多夫，嗯，他也是另一个非常浪漫的人物，他，是的，所以他疯狂地爱上了别人的妻子，是的，他不断地给她写信，不是吗？但他又太尴尬而不敢寄出，三千封
letters he just stores them up yeah and basically And basically, he wants to declare war on Serbia so that he can have a thumping victory, come back and get her. Well, I think, to be fair to him, he's already semi-got her because he has this massive crush on this Gina von Reininghaus. That's it. Who is the wife of an industrialist in Vienna. So Conrad, General Conrad, he had been friends with Franz Ferdinand, actually. He has this crush on this Gina.
信，他只是把它们存起来，是的，基本上，他想对塞尔维亚宣战，这样他就能取得一场辉煌的胜利，回来得到她。嗯，我认为，公平地说，他已经半得到了她，因为他疯狂地迷恋这个吉娜·冯·雷宁豪斯。就是这样。她是维也纳一位实业家的妻子。所以康拉德，康拉德将军，他其实和弗朗茨·斐迪南是朋友。他迷恋这个吉娜。
I think they did start an affair, but they can't get married. And he thinks, well, if I can win a great war, I'll come back and, you know, we'll get married and that'll be absolutely brilliant. And it'd be like gone with the wind, you know, that'll be absolutely tremendous. And so as Chris Clark says in his book, The Sleepwalkers, between 1906 and 1914, Conrad repeatedly counseled preventive wars against Serbia, Montenegro, Russia, Romania, and even Italy. Italy, which was actually Austria's nominal ally at the time. Christopher also says he came to see war as a means of gaining possession of Gina. I mean, there's another potential cause of the First World War.
我想他们确实开始了一段恋情，但他们不能结婚。他想，好吧，如果我能赢得一场伟大的战争，我会回来，你知道，我们会结婚，那将绝对辉煌。那会像《乱世佳人》一样，你知道，那将绝对了不起。所以正如克里斯·克拉克在他的书《梦游者》中所说，在1906年到1914年间，康拉德反复建议对塞尔维亚、黑山、俄罗斯、罗马尼亚甚至意大利进行预防性战争。意大利，当时实际上是奥地利的盟友。克里斯托弗还说，他开始将战争视为获得吉娜的一种手段。我的意思是，这是第一次世界大战的另一个潜在原因。
Now, it's not just, it's obviously too simplistic to say. It's just because of impressing this woman. There are quite a lot of people in Austria who think Serbia is a kind of rogue state. It's a terrorist state. But also, it's become because of impressing this woman there are quite a lot of people in austria who think serbia is a kind of rogue state it's a terrorist state but also it's become dangerous hasn't it so so previously there's uh this guy who describes serbia as a rascally boy trying to steal apples from an orchard but since the two balkan wars yeah serbia has expanded and it's swallowed up kosovo the place of the great battle. And it's got all this French loans, improved its armaments, improved its rail, got a vast new reservoir of manpower. So it's starting to look a bit menacing.
现在，这不仅仅是，说这仅仅是因为给这个女人留下深刻印象显然太简单了。奥地利有相当多的人认为塞尔维亚是一个流氓国家。它是一个恐怖主义国家。但它也变得危险了，不是吗？所以之前，有这个家伙形容塞尔维亚是一个试图从果园偷苹果的顽皮男孩，但自从两次巴尔干战争以来，是的，塞尔维亚扩张了，它吞并了科索沃，那个伟大战斗的地方。它得到了所有这些法国贷款，改善了军备，改善了铁路，拥有了庞大的新人力储备。所以它开始看起来有点威胁性了。
I think that's absolutely right. I think the Austrians think the Serbian threat will only get greater. And Franz Ferdinand thinks the way we deal with it is we change our own internal arrangements so that basically Serbia is no longer a magnet to people inside the empire. But General Conrad and others think, no, we actually just go after Serbia right now, teach it a lesson, and that's the best way to ensure long-term security. But the risk with that is that Serbia is allied to Russia.
我认为那是完全正确的。我认为奥地利人认为塞尔维亚的威胁只会越来越大。而弗朗茨·斐迪南认为我们处理它的方式是我们改变我们自己的内部安排，这样基本上塞尔维亚就不再是帝国境内人们的磁铁了。但康拉德将军和其他人认为，不，我们实际上应该现在就去对付塞尔维亚，给它一个教训，这是确保长期安全的最好方法。但这样做的风险是塞尔维亚是俄罗斯的盟友。
Exactly. The Serbian is its patron. So actually, the person who Franz Ferdinand turns to as an ally in these internal arguments is his fellow rose garden fancier the kaiser so the kaiser is the one person who's actually really nice to him who's kind to him and um a big fan of sophie and a big fan of sophie so for those listeners who are inclined to look poorly on the kaiser yeah because i mean let's be honest the kaiser is a complicated man so shall i read what a top historian has written about this relationship
没错。塞尔维亚是它的保护国。所以实际上，弗朗茨·斐迪南在这些内部争论中求助的盟友是他那同样喜欢玫瑰园的德皇，所以德皇是唯一一个真正对他很好、对他友善的人，嗯，是索菲的忠实粉丝，也是索菲的忠实粉丝，所以对于那些倾向于看低德皇的听众来说，是的，因为说实话，德皇是一个复杂的人，所以我应该读一下一位顶级历史学家关于这种关系的评价吗？
yeah between franz ferdinand and the kaiser the two men loved going hunting together and looked forward to the day when they would be empress together swaggering around with their huge mustaches and ridiculous hats yeah and that top historian dominic was yourself yeah and adventures in time the first world war so they would meet up and they would wear hunting gear and you know compliment each other on their massive mustaches and they would go and shoot some birds and then the kaiser would come back and he would be really nice he would make a point of being nice to sophie so when they went to to germany he goes up in my estimation i feel sorry for sophie yeah the kaiser would say come and sit by me sophie you know he'd be really kind to her all this kind of thing he's wrote letters all the time to franz
是的，在弗朗茨·斐迪南和德皇之间，这两个人喜欢一起去打猎，并期待着他们一起成为皇帝的那一天，留着巨大的胡子，戴着荒谬的帽子，昂首阔步，是的，而那位顶级历史学家多米尼克就是你自己，在《时间冒险：第一次世界大战》中，所以他们会见面，他们会穿上狩猎装备，你知道，互相称赞对方巨大的胡子，他们会去射杀一些鸟，然后德皇会回来，他会表现得非常好，他会特意对索菲好，所以当他们去德国时，他在我心目中的地位上升了，我为索菲感到难过，是的，德皇会说，来坐在我旁边，索菲，你知道，他会对她非常好，所有这些事情，他一直给弗朗茨写信，
ferdinand saying you know don't feel stressed about when your emperor it'll be brilliant we'll have a great time i will be your friend i will always stand by austria all of this stuff it sounds flippant but franz ferdinand is quite a man, ostracized by the rest of the family and by the court. The Kaiser's friendship means a lot to him. And he will often say to the Kaiser, you know, give me a hand here. People are talking of war. The Hungarians have been difficult. You know, use a bit of your influence if you can. And the Kaiser usually says, you know, I'll do what I can. And is it right that the particular moment of crisis is in the wake of these two wars, these two Balkan wars, when Serbia has kind of expanded by something like over 80% of its territory.
斐迪南说，你知道，不要为你成为皇帝感到压力，那会很棒，我们会玩得很开心，我会成为你的朋友，我会永远支持奥地利，所有这些东西，听起来很轻浮，但弗朗茨·斐迪南确实是一个人物，被家族的其他成员和宫廷排斥。德皇的友谊对他意义重大。他经常会对德皇说，你知道，在这里帮我一把。人们在谈论战争。匈牙利人一直很困难。你知道，如果可以的话，利用一下你的影响力。而德皇通常会说，你知道，我会尽我所能。那么，危机发生的特定时刻是在这两次战争，这两次巴尔干战争之后，当时塞尔维亚的领土扩张了大约80%以上，这是对的吗？
Exactly. So the first Balkan war, as we said, October to May 1912, 1913, it's everybody basically ganging up on the Ottomans. Conrad says again and again, let's attack Serbia now. Franz Ferdinand is appalled at this. Let's not stoop to this hooligism let us stay aloof and watch the scum bashing each other's skulls so he doesn't hold the uh the serbs and their antagonists in tremendous regard he actually gives a public toast to peace what would we get
没错。所以第一次巴尔干战争，正如我们所说，1912年10月到1913年5月，基本上每个人都在联合起来对付奥斯曼人。康拉德一次又一次地说，现在攻击塞尔维亚吧。弗朗茨·斐迪南对此感到震惊。不要屈尊于这种流氓行为，让我们保持超然，看着这些渣滓互相敲碎对方的头骨，所以他并不太看重塞尔维亚人和他们的对手，他实际上公开为和平祝酒，我们能从与塞尔维亚的战争中得到什么？我们从击败塞尔维亚中得到的只有……塞尔维亚人严重误读了他，因为我认为他们把奥地利的一种刻板印象投射到了他身上，那是他们意识形态的锚点，是的，他们的意识形态是奥地利是一个欺凌压迫者，是的，弗朗茨·斐迪南留着巨大的胡子，射杀大量的鸟，因此，是的，他也是一个欺凌压迫者，这不符合他们的恶魔学，是的，如果他实际上是一个和平人物，但正如你所说，在第二次巴尔干战争中，每个人都联合起来对付保加利亚，塞尔维亚征服了更多的巴尔干地区，报告传回维也纳，我们有它们，我们知道它们，它们在奥地利驻南巴尔干领事的档案里，说那里有可怕的屠杀，有可怕的种族清洗，整个村庄的阿尔巴尼亚人或自称为土耳其人或穆斯林的人被塞尔维亚准军事部队消灭。所以奥地利人想，哦，塞尔维亚人是坏家伙。然而弗朗茨·斐迪南再次说，不，我们不会卷入。如果我们和塞尔维亚打仗，那将是帝国的终结，因为那意味着与俄罗斯开战。与俄罗斯的战争，他在某处写道，会终结我们。如果奥地利的德皇、奥地利的皇帝和沙皇把对方从王位上拉下来，为革命扫清道路？绝不。
out of war with serbia all we'd get from beating serbia serbs misread him so badly because i think they're projecting onto him a stereotype of austria that is an anchor of their ideology yeah their ideology is austria is a bullying oppressor yeah franz ferdinand has a gigantic mustache and shooting loads of birds ergo yeah he is also a bullying oppressor and it doesn't fit in their demonology yeah if he's actually a sort of peace figure but then as you say in the second balkan war where everybody ganged up on bulgaria the serbs conquered a lot more of the balkans and reports are going back to vienna we have them we know them they're there in the archives from austrian consuls in the southern balkans saying there are horrendous massacres there's horrendous ethnic cleansing going on entire villages of albanians or people who
我的意思是，这非常有先见之明，实际上。这令人惊讶地有先见之明。是的。而且，它确实加剧了悲剧感，真的，这个人死后最终会导致正是那些结果。所以当那场危机在1913年秋天结束时，奥地利人没有卷入。巴尔干战争似乎已经结束了。
describe themselves as turks or muslims wiped out by Serbian paramilitaries. So the Austrians think, oh, the Serbians are very bad guys. And yet again, Franz Furner says, no, we're not going to get involved. It would be the end of the empire if we ever fought a war with Serbia because it would mean war with Russia. A war with Russia, he writes at one point, will finish us. Should the Kaiser of Austria, the Emperor of Austria and the Tsar knock each other off their thrones and clear the way for revolution? No way.
德皇来到科诺皮什切。他们度过了一段绝对辉煌的时光。他们射杀了1100只野鸡。汤姆，关于圣乔治有一些很棒的玩笑。我们刚刚做了一个关于它的播客。是的，你会喜欢这个的。弗朗茨·斐迪南，他的爱好之一是收集圣乔治屠龙的图片。
I mean, it's very prescient, actually. It's amazingly prescient. Yeah. And just, again, it kind of ratchets up the sense of tragedy, really, that this is the man whose death will ultimately result in precisely those results. So when that crisis is over, in the autumn of 1913, the Austrians have not got involved. The Balkan Wars, it seems, have ended.
是的，我应该把它放进播客里。3750种不同的圣乔治屠龙的描绘。他把它们展示给德皇看，他说，看看你把时间浪费在与英国的那场海军竞赛上，建造无畏舰。我已经打败了英国人。我拥有的他们的守护神图像比温莎城堡里的还要多。德皇认为这绝对了不起。
The Kaiser comes to Konopishtah. They have an absolutely brilliant time. They shoot 1,100 pheasants. There's some great banter, Tom, about St. George. We've just done a podcast on it. Yeah, you'll enjoy this. Franz Ferdinand, one of his hobbies was collecting pictures
哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦，哦。我非常喜欢那个。但实际上，实际上，弗朗茨·斐迪南，我的意思是，他很喜欢英国，不是吗？我对那个印象感到非常震惊，以至于我差点晕倒。他实际上在10或20年前对英国非常不满，但到了这一点，他实际上，你知道，他不介意，尤其是因为他们也真的很喜欢在那里射杀鸟类，但我正要说他们对索菲非常好，嗯，还有那个，但主要是关于射杀野鸡，我们是一个爱国播客，我必须说乔治五世和他的宫廷在接下来发生的事情中表现得非常好，因为他们也邀请了索菲和弗朗茨·斐迪南去温莎待了一周，这对索菲来说太棒了，我的意思是这对弗朗茨·斐迪南来说是一件大事，如果你去被认为是欧洲首屈一指的宫廷，并被视为平等对待，他们对索菲很好，那真是太棒了，我的意思是实际上乔治五世的日记对此非常搞笑，周二我们得到了超过一千只野鸡，450只鸭子，周三，我喜欢，我喜欢周五的条目，糟糕的一天，风雨交加，下午下了一场常规的倾盆大雨，但他们仍然得到了800只野鸡和近400只鸭子，尽管在下雨，而且
of St. George and the Dragon. Yeah, I should have put this in the podcast. 3,750 different representations of St. George and the Dragon. And he shows them to the Kaiser and he says, look at you wasting your time
实际上每个人都说大公，他们说他是一个了不起的人。多么辉煌的人。因为没有人比大公更擅长杀鸟了。波特兰公爵，他证明了自己是一流的。他是我的任何朋友的平等。给他足够的练习，他将等同于该国任何最好的射手。高度赞扬。所以每个人都说这太棒了。
with that naval race with the British building dreadnoughts. I've already beaten the British. I have more images of their patron saint than they have in Windsor Castle. And the Kaiser thinks this is absolutely tremendous.
在晚餐时，汤姆，你知道他们坐在谁对面吗？你的朋友，顶级渔夫爱德华·格雷爵士，英国外交大臣，他们谈论世界和平、塞尔维亚、阿尔巴尼亚，他们深入探讨了所有巴尔干地区，爱德华·格雷爵士和每个人都说，哦，大公真是个了不起的人。玛丽王后，大公非常和蔼，他给人留下了极好的印象，他的妻子非常好，随和，容易相处。非常机智。而且实际上，事后，她对某人说，过去非常不英国，但她对他产生了如此好的影响。他们是可爱的人。
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh. I am liking that very much. But actually, actually, Franz Ferdinand, I mean, he's quite keen on Britain, isn't he? I was so shocked at that impression that I nearly fainted. He actually had been very down on Britain about 10 or 20 20 years earlier but by this point he's actually you know he doesn't mind it not least because they are also really into shooting birds there but i was about
那很好。所以他回到奥地利。他对自己非常满意。一切都好。和家人一起过圣诞节。所以这是1913年？1913年。但他确实有一些悬而未决的事情，那就是，
to say they're very nice to sophie well there's that as well but principally it's about shooting pheasants we're a patriotic podcast and i have to say george v and his court very well from what happens next because they also invite sophie and franz fernand over to windsor for a week and this is great for so i mean this is a big deal for franz fernand so if you go to what is considered the kind of premier court in europe and to be treated as equals and they're nice to sophie and that's yeah that's great i mean actually george the fifth's diary is hilarious on this on tuesday we got over a thousand pheasants 450 ducks on wednesday i like i like the entry friday an awful day blowing and pouring with rain a regular deluge in the afternoon but they still got 800 pheasants and nearly 400 ducks even though it's raining and
几个月前，波斯尼亚总督波蒂奥雷克将军对他说了，如果你来波斯尼亚观看我们的军事演习，那不是很好吗？是的，在六月底，去萨拉热窝做个小访问，展示旗帜，对与当地人的关系、哈布斯堡的权威都非常好，所有这些，现在事情是，这又是一个我认为很多人错过的细节，人们说，哦，他真正想去是因为他和索菲可以在一起，所有这些，实际上他并不真的想去，天气会非常热，他对此并不那么热衷，正如我们所说，他的肺部有问题，他非常担心高温，而且他知道，他们都知道存在安全风险，人们常说，是的，他们完全无视安全，那不是真的，淡化它符合总督的利益，因为这会让他看起来是一个更好的总督，但弗朗茨·斐迪南不是白痴，他非常清楚这是一个暗杀的时代，而且总是有风险，但把，我的意思是，把好的方面展现出来，把坏事做到最好，他可以带索菲，因为皇帝非常勉强地给予了许可，不是吗？是的，弗朗茨·斐迪南在6月4日去见他，记得上一集，6月4日是杀手到达萨拉热窝的那一天，同一天，弗朗茨·斐迪南在维也纳去见皇帝，他说，我真的不期待这次访问，天气会很热，我感觉不太好。如果我带上索菲，生活会变得非常轻松。
actually everybody says the arts duke they say he's a wonderful man. What a brilliant man. Because no one is a better killer of birds than the Archduke. The Duke of Portland, he proved himself first class. He's the equal of any of my friends. Give him enough practice, he would be the equal of any of the best shots in the country. High praise. So everyone says it's great.
皇帝破天荒地说，好吧，如果你一定要带上你那该死的妻子。所以他要去了。第二天，当然，就是大使给财政部长发出那个编码警告的那一天。取消它是个好主意。那没有传达给波斯尼亚的当局，传达给总督，所以计划是几乎不会有安全措施，因为重点是表明我们不需要它，不，这是一种常态，所以让我们进入倒计时，弗朗茨·斐迪南在周日
At dinner, Tom, do you know who they sit in opposite? Your friend, top fisherman Sir Edward Grey, british foreign secretary and they talk about world peace serbia albania they go into all the balkans and sir edward gray and everyone says oh what a tremendous man the archduke is queen mary the archduke is most amiable he's making an excellent impression his wife is so nice agreeable and easy to get on with. Very tactful. And actually, afterwards, she says to somebody, used to be very un-English, but she's been such a good influence on him. They're lovely people.
7号，他去了维也纳德比，一切都很棒，每个人都对他和索菲大惊小怪，事实上在第二天的报纸上，很多人评论说她是穿着最好的，她看起来很棒，而且他对此非常满意，接下来的一周，他的老朋友德皇回来了，回来看看玫瑰，设计了他自己的狩猎制服，我喜欢它，我喜欢它，绿色夹克，他有狩猎靴，他有巨大的靴子，他有这顶荒谬的小帽子，他们聊了改革计划，弗朗茨·斐迪南对德皇说，我想让你在匈牙利人问题上帮我，你知道，让他们给农民和斯拉夫人更多的让步，他说做这件事非常关键，他不是傻瓜，弗朗茨·斐迪南，他说
That's nice. So he comes back to Austria. He's very pleased with himself. All good. Has Christmas with his family. So this is 1913? 1913. But he does have something hanging over him, which is,
那个罗马尼亚少数民族非常重要，因为罗马尼亚正在远离我们，走向俄罗斯。我们负担不起疏远罗马尼亚人的代价。因此，我们真的应该考虑匈牙利正在发生的事情，进行改革，并让他们站在我们这边。事实上，德皇说，你知道，我会尽我所能。别担心。你可以依靠我。这次访问非常成功，以至于弗朗茨·斐迪南说
a few months earlier, the governor of Bosnia, General Potiorek, has has said to him wouldn't it be nice if you came to watch our army exercises in bosnia yeah at the end of june do a little visit to sarajevo fly the flag very good for kind of relations with the locals hapsburg authority all of this now the thing is again this is a detail i think a lot of people miss people say oh he what he really wanted to go because he and sophie could be together and all of this actually he doesn't really want to go it's going to be very hot he's not that keen on it he has had as we said problems with his lungs he's very anxious about the heat and he knows they all know that there is a security risk it's often said yeah they are completely oblivious to
这太棒了，夏天结束后，我从波斯尼亚回来，让我们举办一个狩猎周末，你知道
the security that's not really true it's in the governor's interest to downplay it because it'll make him look a better governor but fran fernand is not an idiot he knows perfectly well this is an age of assassinations and there's always a risk but putting i mean putting good spin on it making the best of a bad job he can take Sophie because the emperor kind of very grudgingly gives permission doesn't he does Franz Ferdinand goes to see him on the 4th of June remember from the previous episode the 4th of June is the day the killers arrived in Sarajevo the same day Franz Ferdinand in Vienna goes to see the emperor he says I'm not really looking forward to this it's going to be so hot I'm not feeling. What will make life really easy for me is if I take Sophie.
我们应该邀请谁，乔治五世，所以无论你怎么说第一次世界大战，它挽救了许多鸟类的生命。
And the emperor for once says, fine, if you must take your damned wife with you. So he's going to go. The next day, of course, is the day that there is that sort of coded warning from the ambassador to the finance minister. It would be a good idea to cancel it. That's not passed on to the authorities in bosnia to the governor so the plan is there is going to be very little security because the point is to show that we don't need it no it's a normality so let's get into the sort of countdown franz fernand on sunday
我知道，但这毁了一个本可以辉煌的周末，一个绝对辉煌的周末，我的意思是那实际上是我的梦想晚宴。
the 7th he goes to the vienna derby that's all great everyone makes a fuss of him and sophie and in fact in the next day's papers lots of people comment about how she's the best dressed and she looks great and and he's very pleased with that the following week his old friend the kaiser is back back to look at the roses designed his own hunting uniform love it i love it green jacket and he's got um hunting boots he's got massive boots he's got this ridiculous little hat they have a chat about the reform plans franz fernand says to the kaiser i would like you to help me with the hungarians you know get them to give more concessions to their peasants and the slavs and stuff and he says it's really crucial to do this he's no fool franz fernand he says
来自科斯塔系列的本廷船长，德皇，弗朗茨·斐迪南，乔治五世，我会处于我的元素中，而我只是在想鸟类，是的，你们都是卡特，不是吗，我都是硬的，嗯，当德皇离开后，他们打开了城堡，因为这是他们每年向人们开放参观花园的日子，我想索菲很可爱，这对弗朗茨·斐迪南来说是一件大事。对孩子们很可爱，我想。我想实际上他们相当孤僻。他们并不真正参与太多，因为他们有点害羞。他们是谦虚的人，汤姆。
that romanian minority is really important because roman Romania is moving away from us and towards Russia. We can't afford to alienate the Romanians. Therefore, we should really be thinking about what's going on in Hungary and having reforms and keeping them on side. And actually, the Kaiser says, you know, I'll do my bit. Don't worry. You can rely on me. And the visit is such a success that Franz Ferdinand says
哦。你能说什么？我想他们会出去，表现得很有魅力，你知道。哦，不。我必须让你失望了。擦掉小女孩脸上的鼻涕。那种事。那是你对魅力的定义吗？
this has been brilliant after the summer is over and I'm back from Bosnia let's have a hunting weekend and you know
是的。嗯，某种程度上，是的。好吧，没关系。你知道，人民的女大公。嗯，她不是女大公，是吗？嗯，人民的……公爵夫人。人民的侍女。
who we should have along George V so say what you like about the First World War it saved the lives of a lot of birds
所以现在我们到了周末。他们有一个长周末。他们有多个城堡。所以他们去了他们的夏季城堡，基本上叫克鲁姆，在现在的捷克共和国和奥地利边境。他们只是有一个家庭周末。我的意思是，这听起来基本上像1970年代的英国大篷车假期，他们在树林里长途跋涉，
I know but it ruined what would have been a brilliant weekend an absolutely brilliant weekend I mean that's my dream dinner party actually
他们玩滚球，他们和孩子们玩棋盘游戏，所以孩子们是索菲13岁，马克斯11岁，恩斯特10岁，玩太空跳跳球，你看他们都要去波斯尼亚，这是他们离开孩子们最长的时间，所以这是他们对孩子们的一种告别，我们很快就会回来，我们要去波斯尼亚处理这件事，然后我们会回来，我们可以继续过夏天，所以周三24号，和孩子们告别，他们现在要分开了，索菲要乘火车经布达佩斯，但弗朗茨·斐迪南对海军非常感兴趣，所以他要部分乘船，
Captain Bentin from the Costa series the Kaiser Franz Ferdand george v i'd be in my element whereas i'm just thinking of the birds yeah you're all cart aren't you i'm all hard um when the kaiser is gone they open up the castle because it's their annual open date for people to come and see the gardens i imagine sophie's lovely a big deal for franz finand, this. Lovely to children, I imagine. I think actually they're quite reclusive. They don't really mingle much because they're kind of shy. They're modest people, Tom.
他要从的里雅斯特沿着现在克罗地亚的海岸乘坐一艘无畏舰，实际上是奥地利唯一的一艘无畏舰，然后他将乘游艇沿河进入黑塞哥维那，然后乘火车走剩下的路，当他从维也纳乘火车到的里雅斯特时发生了一件奇怪的事，火车上出现了电气故障，火车变得非常热，因为显然没有风扇，而且他们不得不依靠蜡烛照明，弗朗茨·斐迪南对他的侍从长说，看，这就是它开始的方式，他说，先是一节过热的车厢，然后可能会有人试图在萨拉热窝射杀我，然后如果他们不能完全完成工作，之后船上会发生爆炸。他开了这种玩笑。但他明确表示，我不想
Oh. What can you say? I imagine they're going out and being charming to, you know. Oh, no. I have to disappoint you on that. Wiping the snot from a little girl's face. That kind of thing. Is that your definition of charm?
哦，你能说什么呢？我想他们会出去，表现得很有魅力，你知道的。哦，不，我得让你失望了。给小女孩擦鼻涕，诸如此类的事。这就是你对魅力的定义吗？
Yeah. Well, kind of, yeah. Okay, fine. You know, the people's archduchess. Well, she's not an archduchess, is she? Well, the people's... Duchess. The people's lady-in-waiting.
是啊，嗯，算是吧。好吧，行。你知道，人民的大公夫人。嗯，她不是大公夫人，对吧？好吧，人民的……公爵夫人。人民的侍女。
So now we're at the weekend. They have a long weekend. They have multiple castles. So they go to their summer castle, which is basically called Klum, on the border between what's now the Czech Republic and Austria. And they just have a family weekend. I mean, it basically sounds like a British caravan holiday holiday from the 1970s they go on long walks in the woods
现在到了周末。他们有一个长周末。他们有好几座城堡。所以他们去了他们的避暑城堡，基本上叫克鲁姆，位于现在捷克共和国和奥地利的边界。他们只是过一个家庭周末。我的意思是，这听起来基本上就像20世纪70年代英国人的房车度假，他们在树林里长途跋涉。
they play bowls they play board games with the kids so the kids are sophie's 13 max is 11 and ernst is 10 go on space hoppers and this is you see they're both going to bosnia it's the longest they'll ever have been away from the children so this is their kind of farewell to the children we will be back soon we are going to go to this business in bosnia and then we'll come back and we can crack on with the summer so then on wednesday the 24th goodbye to the children and they're going to go now they're going to go separately sophie's going to go by train via budapest but franz ferdinand is very interested in the navy so he's going to go partly by boat
他们玩滚球，和孩子们玩棋盘游戏，孩子们是13岁的索菲、11岁的马克斯和10岁的恩斯特，玩弹跳球。你看，他们都要去波斯尼亚，这是他们离开孩子最长的一次，所以这是他们对孩子的一种告别，我们很快就会回来，我们要去波斯尼亚处理这件事，然后我们会回来，我们可以继续过夏天。所以到了24号星期三，告别孩子们，他们现在要分开了，索菲要乘火车经布达佩斯去，但弗朗茨·斐迪南对海军非常感兴趣，所以他打算部分乘船去。
he's going to go down a get a kind of dreadnought actually austria's one dreadnought from trieste down the coast of what's now croatia and then he will take a yacht up river into herzegovina and then a train the rest of the way an odd thing happens when he gets the train from vienna to trieste there's an electrical fault on the train and the train gets very hot because there's obviously no fans but also they have to rely on candles for light and franz ferdinand says to his kind of chamberlain see this is how it's going to start he says first an overheated carriage then there'll probably someone will try and shoot me in sarajevo and then if they can't quite finish off the job, there'll be an explosion on board the ship afterwards. He makes this kind of joke. But he says explicitly, I do not want to
他打算乘一艘无畏舰，实际上是奥地利唯一的一艘无畏舰，从的里雅斯特沿着现在克罗地亚的海岸南下，然后他会乘游艇沿河进入黑塞哥维那，剩下的路程乘火车。当他从维也纳乘火车去的里雅斯特时，发生了一件奇怪的事情，火车上出现了电气故障，车厢变得非常热，因为显然没有风扇，而且他们不得不依靠蜡烛照明。弗朗茨·斐迪南对他的侍从长说，看，事情就是这样开始的，他说，先是车厢过热，然后可能会有人在萨拉热窝试图枪杀我，如果他们不能彻底完成任务，之后船上还会发生爆炸。他开了这样一个玩笑。但他明确表示，我不希望
live in a bell jar, under a glass jar. We're always in mortal danger. We just have to put our trust in God. And actually, the rest of the journey unfolds with that incident he goes down the dalmatian coast he gets the yacht then he gets the train and on the 25th of june he arrives in the spa town not far from where we are tom elidja which is up in the hills above us just outside sarajevo sophie is already there and is waiting for him. And at that point, they have three days to live. Brilliant stuff. And in our next episode, we will trace the fateful events
生活在玻璃罩下，时刻处于致命的危险之中。我们只能寄希望于上帝。事实上，接下来的旅程随着那次事件展开，他沿着达尔马提亚海岸南下，坐上了游艇，然后又换乘火车。6月25日，他抵达了离我们不远的一座温泉小镇，就在我们上方萨拉热窝郊外的山上，索菲已经在那里等他了。在那一刻，他们只剩下三天的生命。太精彩了。在下一集中，我们将追溯那些决定性的事件
that lead up to his assassination, a day that changes the world. Bye-bye. Auf Wiedersehen. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix
导致他被暗杀，那一天改变了世界。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐余谈》，这是你们每周的固定节目
of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched
包含娱乐新闻评论、一点演艺圈八卦，在问答环节，我们将揭开娱乐界的幕后，告诉你们这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了
our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集以及提前购买现场演出门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。网址是therestisentertainment.com。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。